haremos un resumen de lo que aprendimos
respecto a las restas hagamos un ejemplo
de estos básicos que nos salen bastante
bien cuánto será 5 - 3
vamos a tomar de nuevo el ejemplo que
teníamos para contar y esta vez
contaremos fresas tenemos una dos tres
cuatro cinco fresas que son estas
primeras y le quitaré o le restar tres
así es que te echaré una dos tres lo que
haré ahora es contar cuántas me quedan
tengo 12 5 menos tres es igual a 2 una
manera más en la que podemos pensar
respecto a esto es la diferencia que hay
si yo tengo 5 o fresas y tú tienes 3
cuánto será aquello que yo tengo más que
tú
esta soy yo y estoy muy feliz hola y
este eres tú y también estás muy feliz
ahora tenemos las 5 ofreces yo tengo una
45 fresas y tú tienes 3 vamos a
cambiarle el color para que sea más
evidente tú tienes 3 1 2
3 si hacemos una comparativa tengo 1 1 2
2 3 3 cuantas fresas tengo de diferencia
tengo una 2
llegamos exactamente al mismo número 2
incluso tenemos también la forma de
revisar esto con la línea de números que
hemos manejado durante mucho tiempo si
tengo aquí mi línea de números empiezo
en 0 1 2 3 4 5 este número 5
empezaré aquí vamos a poner el número de
color verde empezaré aquí en este número
5 y recorrer hacia la izquierda recuerda
que en las restas nos recorremos hacia
la izquierda porque decrecemos quitamos
o nos hacemos más pequeños del 5
quitaremos 3 así es que nos vamos 1 2 3
una vez más llegamos al número 2 lo que
estamos haciendo es ver las diferentes
maneras en las que podemos visualizar
este tipo de restas y existe una más que
está muy divertida a mí me gustó mucho
nos habla de cuál es la diferencia entre
este y este entre el 5 y el 3 pero ahora
de una manera en la línea ya no gráfico
como lo hicimos aquí sino en la línea
este 5 lo encerrar en un cuadro que
equivale a este y si cambiamos el color
ahora en cerrar este número 3
en un color amarillo que será este en la
línea lo podemos ver de la siguiente
manera cuánto es la diferencia o la
distancia que existe entre el 5 y el 3
esto es el 3 y este será el 5 lo estoy
separando para que ustedes vean cuál es
la distancia entre estos y tenemos que
es 12
2 regresamos a este mismo 2 les va
quedando claro tenemos diferentes formas
de visualizar lo tanto contando como por
diferencia gráfica o dentro de la misma
línea podemos decrecer o podemos saber
cuál es la distancia que existe entre
estos dos números hagamos un ejercicio
más
pensemos ahora en cuánto serán 74
imaginemos que tenemos un pedazo de
madera
de 7 metros vamos a contar estos son 7
metros todo esto todo este bloque mide 7
metros
a este bloque le haremos un corte vamos
a dibujar aquí una
un serrucho yukos
digamos que con este ser mucho vamos a
hacer un corte y le quitaremos 4 metros
vamos a hacer nuestro corte aquí cuánto
tendremos ahora sea este bloque de 7
metros le quitamos 4
estos serán los cuatro metros que
cortaremos
cuánto será ahora esta distancia
digamos que aquí tenemos una regla aquí
empezamos en cero
1 1 2 3 4
ok hicimos nuestro corte en los 4 metros
cuánto es esta distancia pues volvemos a
hacer lo que hicimos hace un momento
contamos 1 2 3 esta distancia será de 3
lo que equivale a
74 es igual a 3 o de la siguiente manera
pensemos ahora que ya tenemos un bloque
de 4 metros
este es nuestro bloque de 4 metros y es
de color azul
cuanto necesitamos o de qué tamaño
requiere ser el siguiente bloque que
tengamos para que sumemos 7
pues ahora sabemos que si tenemos un
bloque de 4 y un bloque de 3 metros esto
nos dará un gran gran bloque
equivalente a
7 metros
logran ver la lógica respecto a esto
hagamos uno más estos se empiezan a
poner un poco más interesantes cuántos
eran
17 - 9 vamos a hacer un poco de espacio
para que podamos dibujar
vamos a hacer esta vez la forma gráfica
voy a dibujar 17 pelotas digamos que
tengo 17 pelotas 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15 16 17 pelotas
y a esas pelotas le voy a quitar voy a
regalar o voy a o voy a disminuir 9
quitemos nueve pelotas cambiamos el
color una dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete ocho nueve pelotas he quitado
nueve pelotas entonces cuántas me quedan
una dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho
estas ya no las contaré porque las
elimine estas son únicamente las 8
pelotas que me quedan estamos claros
ahora si ustedes se ponen a hacer esto
de los dibujos con números mucho más
grandes les va a tomar toda la vida
poder llegar a ese número lo que podemos
hacer es lo siguiente volvamos a hacer
nuestra línea
pensemos en ay me quedó mucho acá esta
línea vamos a hacerla más derechita
pensemos en que estamos en el 18
17 16 15 14 13 12 11 10 9 8 7 se puede
todavía está abajo recuerdo en que estas
flechas indican
que los números van hacia arriba o hacia
abajo no siempre empiezan en cero
más adelante verán que incluso existen
números abajo del cero pero lo veremos
en vídeos más adelante eso ahorita no
tiene sentido
ok empecemos entonces ahora en el 17
marquemos este número 17
17 y le restamos 9 es decir nos
recorreremos hacia la izquierda 9
posiciones
vamos 1 2 3 4 5
17 - 9 es igual a 8
y una vez más hacemos la diferencia que
vimos hace un momento de colocar este 17
que está aquí
con este 9 que estará aquí y lo queremos
descontar la diferencia
que existe
en este espacio es más pongámosle aquí
diferencia
que existe
entre los dos números
número lleva acento
ok entonces vamos a contar cuántos son
los espacios que tenemos entre el 17 y
el 9 o si lo pensamos de otra manera
cuánto necesito sumarle a 9 para llegar
al 17 así es que como vamos a pensar en
cuánto sumaremos o añadiremos a 9 para
llegar al 17
ahora nos recorreremos a la derecha y
tenemos que es 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 por lo
que 9 + 8 es igual a 17 de alguna manera
esto tiene sentido aquí tenemos que 17
menos 9 es igual a 8 por lo que
89 es igual a 17 ahora cuánto será 17
menos
17 - 8 es igual a 9 lo podemos ver aquí
17 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 llegamos al 9 y
siempre va a ser y siempre nos va a dar
este mismo resultado tiene la misma
lógica así es que marquemos más o menos
la lógica que tiene esto
al saber que una diferencia es lo que le
necesito sumar algo para llegar a otro
número
qué equivale a ese mismo número total
menos lo que de descontarle para llegar
al número original nos estamos haciendo
bolas vamos a hacer un ejemplo más y
espero que esto quede más claro
cuánto será ahora 13 menos 8 ustedes
pueden hacer estos ejercicios entre el
10 y el 20 hagan restas de números de un
solo dígito es decir a 14 menos 5 a 17
menos 2 con esto ustedes pueden ir
practicando poco a poco en este caso
haremos 13 menos
8 así es que hagamos nuestra línea de
números
pensemos en el 14 13 12 11 10 9 8 7 6 5
4 y una vez más dejemos que esta línea
se vaya hacia abajo coloquémonos en el
vamos a arrestar por lo que nos vamos a
la izquierda y nos iremos a la izquierda
ocho posiciones vamonos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
13 - 8 es igual a 5 hagamos de una vez
la diferencia para ver si esto es
correcto tenemos el número 13 ubicado
aquí y tenemos el número 8 ubicado aquí
cuál será la diferencia entre estos dos
espacios
contemos 1 2 3 4 5 se dan cuenta es
exactamente lo mismo que habíamos visto
5 y veamos una vez más que entonces
13 - 8 es igual a 5 es una manera de
volver a escribir lo que tenemos aquí
arriba y vimos que si yo a 8 que está
aquí le sumo
5 como lo contamos aquí
23 45 85 es igual a 13 o de la misma
manera 13 menos
5 será igual a vamos a cambiar el color
para hacerlo obvio 13
5 1 2 3 4 5 tenemos 8 es exactamente lo
mismo que decíamos hace un momento si yo
a 13 le quito 8 sólo tendré 5 o si a 8
le sumó 5 llegaré al 13 de igual manera
si yo a 13 le quito 5 es 8 lo veremos
con más detalle más adelante sin embargo
es importante que ustedes vayan
practicando poco a poco con estos
números que les decía números de dos
cifras entre el 10 y el 20 para
eliminarle números con una sola cifra y
así podrán poco a poco ir entendiendo
esto más haremos muchos más ejercicios
en los vídeos que vienen y poco a poco
dominaremos mucho más este arte de las
restas nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo